notre notre séance et dans le plaisir
d'accueillir madame Dominique Lottin qui
vient devant la commission comme on l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure dans le cas des
dispositions de l'article 13 et la
Constitution car elle est proposée pour
être nommé par le président du Sénat
monsieur Gérard Larcher
au Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
je vous redis à toutes et à tous que
cette audition madame et
suivi en vidéo et elle peut être vu sur
internet en direct sur le site du Sénat
à l'instant où nous parlons
et je rappelle au collègues qu'à l'issue
de l'audition de même le temps nous
procéderons vote de bulletin secret et
qu'il n'y a pas de pouvoir possible le
vote est personnel exclusivement
personnel et nous découvrons
immédiatement à l'issue de ce vote
madame merci de votre présence je crois
que chacun sachant pourquoi vous êtes là
je vais vous donner la parole pour que
vous teniez le propos qu'il vous plaira
dans le cadre de cette proposition faite
par le président du Sénat et sans doute
que certains de collègues auront
la volonté de vous poser également
quelques questions au global on s'est
donné 45 minutes pour que les choses
pour avoir un timing puisque nous étions
tous les candidats ce matin à la fois du
président du Sénat bien sûr mais aussi
du président de la République madame le
thym vous avez la parole
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs de
m'accueillir au sein de votre commission
et je remercie bien sûr le président
Larcher de me témoigner sa confiance en
me proposant comme personnalité
qualifiée pour exercer les fonctions de
membres du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
pour vous exposer comment j'envisage si
votre commission approuve ma désignation
d'exercer ses fonctions vous ne serez
pas étonné compte tenu de mon parcours
professionnel que j'ai pris soin de
relire avec attention les articles 64 et
65 de la Constitution consacrée au CSM
et à ses missions force est de constater
que si le constituant de 2008 a décidé
de mettre fin à la présidence du Conseil
par le Président de la République et à
sa vice-présidence par le garde des
sceaux et qu'il a réaffirmé la place
et le rôle du CSM pour garantir
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
il ne vient pas pour autant me
semble-t-il et sous réserve de votre
appréciation instaurer un conseil de
justice qui serait chargé comme cela
existe dans d'autres pays européens de
l'administration et de la gestion de la
justice
ainsi les deux missions principales
confiées au CSM demeurent en l'état des
textes d'une parcelle relative à la
nomination des magistrats et d'autre
part celle du respect de la déontologie
et de la discipline des magistrats
j'ai bien conscience que ces deux
missions sont particulièrement lourdes
et délicate puisqu'il s'agit de garantir
au justiciable d'être jugé par un tiers
indépendant et impartial mais aussi par
un magistrat compétent diligent
irréprochable et respectueux des droits
de celui qui se présente devant lui
l'indépendance des magistrats qu'ils
soient du siège ou du parquet c'est
d'abord et avant tout une protection
pour le justiciable même si l'importe
aussi bien sûr de garantir au magistrats
de pouvoir exercer librement leur office
sans pression ni intimidation
par ailleurs si le CSM réunit en
formation plénière est également chargée
de répondre aux demandes d'avis
formulées par le Président de la
République il n'est pas me semble-t-il
chargé de réaliser un travail de
doctrine sur l'avenir de la justice
naturellement cela n'interdit pas au CSM
de contribuer à la réflexion lorsqu'il
est sollicité dans le cadre des travaux
notamment parlementaire pouvant avoir
une incidence sur l'indépendance de
l'autorité judiciaire ou le statut des
magistrats il est d'ailleurs
légitimement et fréquemment sollicité
dans ces domaines il doit aussi bien sûr
rendre compte de son activité
communiquer sur ses travaux et
participer aux rencontres et aux
échanges avec ces homologues européens
mais même si la tentation est alors
forte de prendre par au débat public
lorsqu'il porte sur l'institution
judiciaire ou à des incidences sur
celle-ci je reste convaincu que le CSM
ne doit le faire qu'avec parcimonie et
qu'il ne lui appartient pas dans piété
pardon sur les prérogatives du
gouvernement ni sur scène du Parlement
et si j'ai toujours eu la conviction que
l'autorité judiciaire un cycle CSM
organes constitutionnel chargé donc de
contribuer à garantir son indépendance
avec une place particulière au sein de
l'État cette conviction s'est renforcée
et à évoluer depuis que j'ai quitté il y
a plus de 5 ans la magistrature et que
j'ai eu l'honneur de siéger comme
membres du Conseil constitutionnel
le conseil est en effet très
régulièrement saisi de questions le
conduisant à définir la place le rôle et
les contours de l'autorité judiciaire
les procédures furent nombreuses dans
ces domaines ces dernières années je
n'en citerai que quelques exemples la
dernière loi de programmation de la
justice les lois de sécurité intérieure
ou encore les régimes de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire dans lequel s'est
posé la question cruciale des modalités
de contrôle des mesures de restriction
des libertés individuelles en outre
plusieurs questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalités nous ont conduit à
traiter de la question Stains sensible
du statut du parquet
le fait également d'avoir eu au sein du
Conseil constitutionnel à aborder bien
d'autres sujets et principes qui
touchent au fonctionnement même de
l'État des collectivités territoriales
et des institutions et le fait de
travailler avec des personnalités au
parcours particulièrement riche et
extrêmement divers tout cela m'a permis
de m'enrichir d'acquérir de nouvelles
compétences et de porter un autre regard
un regard distancier sur l'institution
judiciaire
naturellement je n'oublie pas
l'institution judiciaire à laquelle j'ai
appartenu et dans laquelle j'ai exercé
l'essentiel de ma carrière dans les
fonctions juridictionnelles les plus
variées au pénal comme au civils en
première instance comme en appel et
pendant près de dix années dans des
fonctions administratives et de
direction au sein du ministère de la
justice notamment comme adjointe du
secrétaire général puis comme directrice
des
ce qui me permet de bien connaître de
l'intérieur le monde de la justice et
ses modes de fonctionnement et j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que cela pourrait
être un atout pour siéger au Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature comme cela
m'a aidé dans mes fonctions de membres
du Conseil constitutionnel
et en tant que membre de ce Conseil
constitutionnel il m'a aussi fallu
aborder les questions touchant à
l'institution judiciaire en toute
indépendance et avec un regard extérieur
c'est ce que je me suis employée à faire
même si je le reconnais cela n'a pas été
simple dans les premiers mois à cette
gare me revient en mémoire une anecdote
que je vous livre pour illustrer mon
propos
après quelques mois de fonction alors
que comme tous les jeudis nous
déjeunions à l'issue de notre séance
dans la salle à manger du Conseil le
président Fabius m'a fait observer que
depuis quelques semaines j'avais
abandonné l'expression par laquelle je
débutais trop souvent mes interventions
assez en séance à savoir nous les
magistrats judiciaires pour utiliser
désormais le nous et m'inclure ainsi
comme membres de ce conseil je vous
avoue que cette observation m'a fait
réfléchir et prendre conscience que
j'avais sans doute franchi une étape
indispensable à l'exercice de mes
fonctions et qu'il me fallait poursuivre
mes efforts pour me détacher
définitivement de l'institution
judiciaire à laquelle j'avais appartenu
je crois pouvoir dire que j'y suis
parvenue et que j'ai ainsi pu porter sur
cette institution un regard critique au
sens premier et positif du terme
soyez assurés que si vous confirmez ma
nomination comme personnalité qualifiée
du Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
c'est avec la même indépendance le même
regard critique la même impartialité
intégrité et dignité que j'exercerai mes
fonctions et que je veillerai en toute
circonstances à ce qu'aucun soupçon ne
puisse se faire jour en matière
d'indépendance du CSM
j'ajoute que pour clore la discussion
juridique qui ces dernièrement faites
jour j'ai décidé de renoncer
définitivement à la possibilité qui
m'était offerte par l'article 77 de
l'ordonnance statutaire de 1958 de me
prévaloir de l'honorariat
s'agissant de la domination des
magistrats la mission essentielle
confiée au CSM et donc celle de
rechercher la personne la plus qualifiée
pour occuper le bon poste au bon moment
et ainsi de contribuer à définir une
politique de gestion des ressources
humaines la plus cohérente et la plus
efficace possible
j'ajoute
que l'équilibre trouvé dans un partage
des compétences entre la direction des
services judiciaires et le CSM et un
contrôle réciproque de chacun me paraît
de nature à mieux garantir
l'indépendance de la magistrature et a
laissé au garde des sceaux
l'administration générale et la
définition des orientations nécessaires
à la conduite des politiques judiciaires
et à la mise en oeuvre des réformes
décidées par le gouvernement et voter
par le Parlement
en matière de nomination des magistrats
la tâche du CSM est particulièrement
lourde pour les membres communs amenés à
statuer sur plus de 2300 mouvements par
an dans environ 80 portent sur des
nominations à son initiative elle exige
une disponibilité importante et un
engagement sans faille
par ailleurs le nombre de ces mouvements
interroge sur la question délicate de la
mobilité des magistrats trop rapide pour
certains d'entre eux inexistantes pour
d'autres à cet égard les préconisations
formulées par votre commission sont
toujours d'actualité qu'il s'agisse du
rythme des transparences des durées
minimales et maximales d'exercices des
fonctions du renfort de l'attractivité
de certaines juridictions notamment par
des incitations financières et
d'ancienneté
c'est à ce prix que pourra être maintenu
la carte territoriale des juridictions
et il est tout aussi important que les
magistrats s'inscrivent dans la vie des
territoires dont ils sont un acteur
social de premier ordre comme j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de le dire à votre
commission ce n'est pas la même chose de
rendre la justice dans les
Hauts-de-France ou en Normandie
malheureusement
faute de temps mais aussi par peur de ce
compromettre une grande majorité de
magistrats se sont repliées sur
eux-mêmes évitant les échanges avec leur
partenaire institutionnels et même avec
les barreaux
se repli sur soi et dévastateur à plus
d'un titre et contribue aussi j'en suis
convaincue à la perte de sens qui frappe
les jeunes générations il faut leur
redonner du temps pour s'ouvrir aux
autres et reprendre leur place dans la
cité pour ce faire je crois comme vous
qu'il faut développer les équipes
pluridisciplinaires autour des
magistrats et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nourrit de l'expérience du
Conseil constitutionnel ou le travail en
équipe est une réalité
j'ai engagé un travail de réflexion sur
ce sujet
le CSM devra prendre sa part pour
accompagner ce changement de culture en
valorisant le parcours de ceux qui
souhaiteront à l'issue de ce travail
d'assistance intégré la magistrature
j'ajoute qu'il me semble important de
diversifier encore davantage le
recrutement des magistrats pour que le
corps de la magistrature soit à l'image
de la population constituée d'individus
plus ou moins jeunes directement
issue de l'université ou ayant une
expérience professionnelle antérieure et
qui apporte du sang neuf à la
magistrature
j'ajoute encore que le développement de
l'Open Data des décisions de justice va
très certainement révolutionner le
fonctionnement des juridictions et que
là aussi il faudra que les magistrats
soient prêts à affronter ces
bouleversements
même si beaucoup d'autres choses
pourraient être développées sur la GRH
des magistrats le temps méconté je
voudrais maintenant dire quelques mots
sur la deuxième mission confiée au CSM
tout aussi essentielle celle de la
déontologie et de la discipline des
magistrats
force est de constater que dans ce
domaine des améliorations sensibles
s'avèrent nécessaires et qu'en
particulier la création en 2011 de la
possibilité de saisine du CSM par tout
juste icible n'est toujours pas
opérationnel en effet après dix années
de fonctionnement seul 13 dossiers ont
donné lieu à une décision de renvoi
devant la formation disciplinaire certes
la très grande majorité des saisines
sont irrecevables parce qu'elles portent
sur le fond de la décision rendue mais
il n'en demeure pas moins que le mode de
saisine ne répond pas à la volonté du
législateur de renforcer la confiance
des citoyens dans l'institution
judiciaire
de même en matière de déontologie et de
discipline est-il indispensable
d'adopter une vision globale de la
question depuis la formation des
magistrats la mise en place de tutorat
le retour à la collégialité et bien sûr
aussi les questions touchant à
l'évaluation des magistrats et à la
nécessaire nécessité de prononcer dans
un certain nombre de cas des sanctions
disciplinaires
naturellement également il est
indispensable de trouver un juste
équilibre entre l'impératif
d'exemplarité qui s'impose à tout
magistrat pour garantir une justice
impartiale et de qualité et la nécessité
de sauvegarder l'indépendance
juridictionnelle des magistrats et la
sérénité des conditions d'exercices de
leur office
j'ai bien conscience que cet équilibre
est particulièrement difficile à trouver
et que dans ce domaine comme pour tous
les autres attributions confiées au
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature il
faut se garder d'avoir des a priori et
des idées préconçues définitives
quelle que soit son parcours et son
expérience professionnelle je reste
convaincu que l'exercice de nouvelles
fonctions exige un regard neuf et un
investissement personnel pour compléter
ses connaissances et acquérir les
compétences nécessaires ainsi que la
capacité à oeuvrer à une mission
collective et à s'enrichir des échanges
avec les autres membres
c'est tout l'intérêt de travailler au
sein d'une collégialité
soyez assurés que je suis prête à cet
investissement et à travailler dans cet
état d'esprit si vous me faites
l'honneur de donner un avis favorable à
la proposition de nomination du
président du Sénat
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
suit à présent à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions merci madame je
vais donner la parole à ceux qui la
demande et je crois que Jean-Pierre
Sueur
solliciter la parole entier merci Madame
madame d'abord je tiens à souligner
les qualités éminentes dont vous avez
fait preuve et la haute qualité de votre
parcours
une fois que j'ai dit cela je voudrais
revenir même si cela pourra vous
paraître quelque peu irritant sur le
débat qui est intervenu récemment sur la
question de la parité et notamment sur
l'attachement d'un certain nombre de
membres de la magistrature aussi de
d'autres personnes au fait qu'il y ait
une majorité de personnalités qualifiée
donc de personnalité de la partenaire
pas à la magistrature au sein des
formations du CSM
et à cet égard la question s'est posée
de votre statut et je remarque que vous
avez traité de la question avec une
grande subtilité puisque la déclaration
de Monsieur Fabius semble considérer je
crois dans votre esprit qu'il y a une
sorte de videuité c'est à dire que d'une
certaine façon vous vous étiez quelque
peu détachés des fonctions antérieures
alors je vais vous demander carrément
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
histoire de parité ou de non parité et
comment vous appréhender cela
merci Monsieur on va prendre peut-être
plusieurs questions madame Laurence à
Ribet
merci président merci pour votre exposé
préalable
vous avez insisté sur un moment donné
sur la les ressources humaines et la
recherche de la personne ne la plus
qualifiée et j'aimerais vous interroger
en fait sur la question de la présence
des femmes quand on regarde un peu les
choses on se rend compte que dans les
grandes juridictions dites du groupe 1
et 2 les femmes sont très peu
représentées dans les fonctions de
président des tribunaux judiciaires et
premier président de cour d'appel
et c'est le dernier rapport du CSM qui
le montre et par contre elles deviennent
majoritairement candidates dans les dans
les groupes 3 et 4
et donc je voulais savoir
comment vous quel était votre regard sur
sur cette sur cet état et comment vous
envisagez la possibilité de faire
évoluer les choses
merci Madame Marie Monsieur Philippe
bonne Carrère
merci monsieur le Président deux
observations rapides la première pour
souligner que le début de discussion sur
votre statut d'ancien magistrat m'est
apparu madame relativement braquer un
avantage
d'abord j'avoue que je comprends pas
très bien en quoi
cela pourrait être votre parcours
professionnel de magistrat pour être
d'inconvénient pour votre participation
au CSM et sans être discours tout à
vis-à-vis de quiconque la question
pourrait être peut-être aussi posée pour
un ancien garde des sceaux qui a procédé
lui-même à des nominations de magistrats
en tout cas et pour en terminer sur ce
sujet il me semble que la manière
élégante avec laquelle vous avez réglé
cette question et que vous nous avez
présenté tout à l'heure et tout à fait
satisfaisant deuxième observation qui
était au départ une question à laquelle
vous avez déjà répondu est-ce qu'il va
me permettre d'aller très vite j'étais
très j'avais l'intention de vous
interroger sur l'enseigne vous avez pu
recueillir de votre parcours au Conseil
constitutionnel et en quoi ils pouvaient
éclairer votre rôle au niveau du CSM
j'avoue que ceci a constitué une partie
importante de votre propos tout à
l'heure aussi je me permettrai de
retirer ma question et ce qui manque la
réponse nous a été fournie et bien sûr
pertinente merci Monsieur bonnecardère
Madame Muriel jourdat
merci monsieur le Président j'ai une
question qui a trait à l'indépendance
des magistrats que vous avez déjà évoqué
madame
il me semble que l'indépendance du
magistrat et le fait qu'il le soit un
féodé à personne et c'est
essentiellement un soutien de son
impartialité je pense que nous
partageons cette position si j'ai bien
compris vos propos pour autant on a le
sentiment que certains magistrats
estiment que leur indépendance signifie
qu'ils peuvent exprimer leurs opinions à
travers leur décision je pense par
exemple à cette décision du juge de
première instance qui suite au vol du
portrait du Président de la République
dans une mairie par des militants
écologistes avait estimé que ce vol
était justifié par l'inaction climatique
du gouvernement ce qui est plus une
position politique une position de droit
me semble-t-il
pour autant c'est indépendance
me semble la garante de la crédibilité
de la justice auprès des justiciables
comment faire pour qu'elle soit comprise
dans le bon sens par ce la même qui
doivent l'exercer c'est-à-dire les
magistrats
merci Madame Jordan Monsieur Alain
Richard
une certaine
cette frustration à tenir ce dialogue
avec les candidats à la nomination que
nous recevons en particulier quand aussi
bien la fonction vers laquelle il se
destinent que celles qu'ils ont
exprimées et occupés auparavant sont
tout assortis d'une obligation de secret
des délibérations donc ça fait quand
même énormément de sujets de dialogue
qui s'estompe
et sur le sujet du statut professionnel
ou
institutionnel des personnes qui
viennent sierger au Conseil
constitutionnel moi qui ai vu pendant
mes années au Conseil d'État arrivé
un grand nombre de personnes
issues tour extérieur qui avait donc
fait l'objet d'une nomination qui ne
prédisposait pas absolument à
l'indépendance
j'ai remarqué
l'aptitude
au devoir d'ingratitude de la totalité
de ces personnalités et ça me rappelle
d'ailleurs
l'illustre exemple de Vidocq à savoir
que souvent les meilleurs policiers sont
des malfaiteurs repentis
mais je voudrais tout de même poser une
question
madame la Présidente l'automne qui est
le sujet
de
la disponibilité si j'ose dire du corps
des magistrats pour les détachement
et pour une effective mobilité dans
d'autres fonctions de service public
il me semble
repérable mais je vois ça évidemment un
peu trop loin que
il y a des exceptions à ça
mais que le choix d'un magistrat qui
soit d'ailleurs du siège ou de du
ministère public
de partir en détachement il accomplir
une fraction de sa carrière
ne le conduit pas ou ne la conduit pas
très fréquemment à accéder aux fonctions
les plus ne plus haute responsabilités
et j'aimerais savoir si en tant que
membre du Conseil supérieur
vous seriez intéressé avec
particulièrement à ce sujet là puisque
il y a déjà des tas d'obstacles à la
mobilité extérieure des magistrats du
fait de la pression sur les ressources
humaines du corps mais il semble en plus
que la réaction collective de
l'institution ne soit pas de les
favoriser
merci Monsieur Richard est-il d'autres
questions
moi je n'aurais peut-être une même le
temps
le corps des magistrats et en fait son
recrutement les voies d'accès
diclatérales représentent à peu près 20%
du corps de la magistrature or le Garde
des Sceaux a annoncé récemment en
recrutement massif pour remettre à
niveau de juridiction de plus de 1500
magistrats à se faire de ma part on
corrigera si je dis une erreur
comment vous vous envisagez cette vous
imaginez en tous les cas cette
diversification des recrutements ce
niveau de recrutement est donc sa
diversification
singulièrement pour maintenir un niveau
juridique
important au niveau juridique au niveau
de compétences
on vous laisse la parole immédiatement
alors pour répondre d'abord à la
première question que vous m'avez posée
monsieur Suarez
je crois que évidemment qu'elle est
importante mais elle est importante
surtout à travers les parcours des
personnes qui se présentent
au sein de cette institution et je crois
que la volonté aussi mais je parle là
aussi sous votre contrôle
du constituant de 2008 c'était d'éviter
incorporatisme ça a été dit ça a été
écrit alors le corporatisme qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est l'attitude d'un corps
qui se protège et qui tente de défendre
exclusivement les intérêts donc de ce
corps et de ceux qui le servent c'est à
dire les magistrats je crois que c'est
ça avant tout la volonté du législateur
en 2008 alors je crois que le fait
d'avoir appartenu à l'institution
judiciaire je dis bien appart
puisque je n'appartiens plus à cette
institution et bien pour autant ce n'est
pas une raison pour défendre avec
corporatisme ce corps est d'ailleurs je
relève que ceux qui ont engagé ce débat
sont ceux qui me reprochaient lorsque
j'étais directeur des services
judiciaires de ne pas défendre
suffisamment les magistrats donc c'est
ça m'a fait quelque peu sourire de ce
point de vue je voudrais plus
sérieusement vous dire que
lorsque le président Larcher m'a proposé
pour occuper les fonctions de membres du
Conseil constitutionnel après 35 ans de
fonctions dans la magistrature c'est
vrai que ça n'a pas été sans impassement
au coeur que j'ai quitté ce corps et je
dis bien quitter parce que dès lors que
je suis rentrée au conseil je n'ai
jamais eu l'intention de revenir au sein
du corps judiciaire j'avais pris cette
décision alors pour des raisons
strictement administratives je me suis
placé en position de détachement pour
des raisons de retraite tout simplement
je le dis mais voilà je savais que je ne
reviendrai plus au sein du corps
judiciaire d'ailleurs j'ai entamé une
procédure pour demander ma mise à la
retraite presque un an avant et ce n'est
que pour des questions purement
administratives que j'ai dû revenir dans
le corps parce que on peut pas
demander sa retraite au milieu d'un mois
et en plus j'avais des difficultés de
calcul et donc je suis revenu pour un
mois et demi au sein du corps si je puis
dire mais vraiment pour des raisons
strictement administratives et c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs j'avais
engagé ce travail sur les équipes autour
des magistrats parce que je me voyais
mal être payé par l'État et ne rien
faire pendant ce mois et demi là voilà
mais pour moi c'est bien en 2017 que
j'ai quitté ce corps et donc je voilà
j'espère avoir ainsi répondu à votre
question
alors pour répondre à Madame Marie B sur
la question de la présence des femmes
c'est c'est vrai que c'est une
difficulté
on a une majorité de femmes aujourd'hui
au sein de la magistrature mais on a
beaucoup de difficultés à ce que ces
femmes accèdent et souhaitent accéder
parce qu'il y a de ça aussi à des postes
de responsabilité ça vient un peu à peu
mais il faut les aider
j'ai tenté à la place qui était la
mienne de toujours aider des candidates
ça n'est pas chose aisée alors je pense
qu'il faut les aider aussi par peut-être
des questions
peut-être des questions d'ordre matériel
aussi tout simplement tout autant que
les hommes mais surtout à leur donner
confiance et envie d'occuper ces
fonctions donc c'est vrai que c'est une
préoccupation que j'ai toujours eu et
que je continuerai à voir au sein du
CNCF
voilà alors Monsieur bonne Carrère je
crois que j'ai pas à répondre vous avez
répondu pour moi aux observations que
j'avais faites au cours de mon
intervention alors madame Jorda
sur
l'indépendance des magistrats
l'impartialité
l'expression de leur opinion
c'est quelque chose qui m'a toujours
préoccupé et je vous rejoins dans la
nécessité qu'effectivement
à partir du moment où nous endossons la
robe de magistrat quand on porte une
robe quelle qu'elle soit d'ailleurs et
quand on endosse des fonctions
ce ne sont pas assez opinions
personnelles qui doivent prévaloir bien
évidemment mais
la loi rien que la loi et l'application
de la loi de manière la plus impartiale
possible alors sur le cas dont vous avez
fait auquel vous avez fait référence je
crois qu'il y a une décision de justice
et qui concerne donc je ne ferai pas
d'autres
observations mais il en vaille bien
évidemment de la crédibilité et que
exprimer son opinion
ça peut dans un certain nombre de cas
relevés effectivement d'une d'une la
faute professionnelle qui mérite à tout
le moins des rappels déontologiques
alors Monsieur Alain Richard
sur la disponibilité du corps
pour
occuper des fonctions en détachement
je crois que c'est un enrichissement
effectivement que des magistrats
accèdent à d'autres fonctions puis
reviennent dans le corps repartent etc
ça a toujours été extrêmement délicat un
peu moins maintenant
de par certaines jurisprudences du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
considérait quelquefois que ça avait été
un privilège pour eux et que il fallait
pas leur donner un autre privilège en
leur donnant un retour trop bénéfique
dans le corps mais je crois que c'est
une question importante et que
évidemment on se nourrit de ces échanges
et ça me paraît essentiel que de le
favoriser
voilà quant au recrutement massif
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président
buffet je crois qu'ils sont
indispensables parce que tous les
travaux des montres qu'effectivement on
manque cruellement de magistrats comme
de fonctionnaires d'ailleurs de greffe
il est important aussi parce que l'un ne
va pas sans l'autre de compléter les
juridictions
pour autant il ne faut pas effectivement
baisser le niveau
en conséquence
je crois que je vous l'ai dit dans mon
propos je suis favorable à ce qu'on
maintienne un concours de
l'administrature ouvert aux étudiants
mais il faut pas ouvrir évidemment un
nombre de places qui ferait que le
niveau du concours baisse et donc la
qualité de la justice risque de s'en
ressentir je pense que donc il est par
voie de conséquence absolument
nécessaire et je vous l'ai dit je pense
que l'ouverture de la magistrature a des
personne qui ont un autre parcours
professionnel
et quelque chose de tout à fait
bénéfique d'ailleurs c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé mais
encore davantage peut-être demain avec
ces recrutements massifs et urgent pour
mettre à niveau l'institution et faire
en sorte que on rende la justice dans
des délais raisonnables ce qui est
malheureusement pas toujours le cas
j'espère avoir répondu à l'ensemble de
vos questions merci Madame effectivement
parce que chacun a été a eu la réponse
qui
à la question qu'il avait posée s'il n'y
a pas d'autres
questions à moi que vous souhaitiez
rajouter quelque chose et bien je vous
propose de vous remercier de vue ce
matin et et de vous libérer
immédiatement
merci beaucoup
merci à vous
quand vous voulez quand vous voulez
bien chers collègues
nous continuons nos auditions et nous
recevons maintenant Monsieur Patrick
Titien à qui je vais laisser la parole
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
proposé pour être nommé au Conseil
Supérieur magistrature par le Président
de la République et c'est assez occasion
que nous l'auditionnons ce matin et je
vais lui laisser la parole tout de suite
de façon à vous dire ensuite qu'il y
aura des questions probablement des
collègues et que nous avons globalement
45 minutes
je vous en prie je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le président
c'est évidemment un moment extrêmement
solennelle et je me présente devant vous
avec beaucoup d'humilité comme vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le Président le
président de la République a bien voulu
vous soumettre ma candidature pour
siéger au Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature l'organe statutaire qui
l'assiste dans sa mission de garant de
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
comme vous le savez également outre les
avis qu'il rend au président de la
République et au garde des sceaux le
Président le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature a une double fonction il
est un organe finalement de ressources
humaines puisque c'est lui qui procède
nominations des hauts magistrats du
siège de la Cour de cassation les
premiers présidents de cour d'appel les
présidents des tribunaux judiciaires
il donne son avis sur les nominations
des magistrats du ministère public et il
est à côté de cela à l'organe
disciplinaire de la magistrature de
l'ordre judiciaire je vais vous
présenter mon parcours professionnel et
en insistant plus particulièrement sur
les aspects de ce parcours qui sont en
lien avec l'activité du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
je suis entré en 1983 il y a 40 ans
presque jour pour jour à l'École
nationale de la magistrature et j'ai
effectué un stage dans la ruralité au
tribunal de grande instance de Guingamp
et à l'issue de cette formation j'ai été
nommé juge au tribunal de grande
instance de Metz chargé du service du
tribunal d'instance pour reprendre la
terminologie qui était en vigueur à
l'époque et qui a été modifié au fil des
ans
je suis resté cinq ans au tribunal
d'instance de Metz et en 1990 j'ai
quitté définitivement la juridiction
j'ai été alors nommé au ministère des
averses étrangères en qualité secrétaire
des affaires étrangères et dans ses
fonctions j'avais un double rôle d'abord
il s'agissait de défendre la France
devant ce qui était alors les organes de
la Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme la Commission européenne des
droits de l'homme qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
et la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme qui n'était à l'époque pas
directement accessible par les
justiciables
j'ai donc dans ce dans cette fonction
travailler principalement sur des
dossiers où il y avait des
dysfonctionnements du service public de
la justice des longueurs de détention
provisoire des longueurs de procédures
civile des atteintes à la présomption
d'innocence des dysfonctionnements de
toute nature et le rôle qui était le
nôtre dans l'équipe à laquelle
j'appartenais était de défendre la
France et aussi d'essayer de faire des
règlements amiable avec les requérants
l'autre partie de mon travail était une
partie de négociation négociation pour
la France d'un traité international le
protocole numéro 11 à la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme qui a
été négocié enfin que j'ai négocié
pendant plusieurs années qui aboutit le
1er novembre 1998 à la création de la
nouvelle Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme tel que nous la connaissons tous
aujourd'hui cette cour unique et
permanente que les justiciables peuvent
saisir directement
en
1994 j'ai intégré après avoir passé un
concours le Conseil de l'Europe
cette organisation était au mi-temps des
années 90 confronté à une véritable
transformation une mutation importante
puisqu'elle accueillait en son sein
les pays d'Europe centrale et orientale
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque les pecots
qui connaissaient leur transition vers
la démocratie
mon rôle a alors consisté à former
aux valeurs du Conseil de l'Europe
c'est-à-dire la démocratie
la préminence du droit et bien sûr
surtout la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme les magistrats et les
avocats de ces pays d'Europe centrale et
orientale j'ai aussi participé à la
création dans ces pays d'institution qui
était connu à l'ouest mais qui
n'existait pas derrière le rideau de fer
des institutions telles que les écoles
de la magistrature tels que les
médiateurs sur le modèle du Médiateur de
la République français tel qu'il
existait à l'époque et évidemment les
conseils supérieurs de justice ou
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pour ce faire je me suis appuyé sur
l'expertise de membres du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et ce fut
mais mon premier contact avec cette
institution cette période de ma vie
professionnelle a été très marquante
parce que j'ai pu à l'époque rencontrer
beaucoup de juges de ces pays et
notamment des juges roumains qui avaient
exercé leur métier sous la dictature de
chaouchecu et qui m'ont expliqué en fait
ce que cela signifiait d'être un juge
dans un pays où il n'y avait pas
d'indépendance de la justice où les
juges n'étaient pas indépendants où ils
pouvaient du jour au lendemain être muté
d'un bout à l'autre du pays parce qu'ils
avaient rendu une décision qui n'était
pas satisfaisante pour leurs autorités
je mesure encore aujourd'hui
l'importance que l'inamovabilité des
magistrats représente dans notre système
français
à partir de 1998 c'est la quatrième
partie de mon parcours j'ai
été nommé conseiller juridique au sein
de l'organisation et là encore ce
travail avait un lien avec l'émission du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature en
effet je me suis occupé d'affaires
disciplinaire qui concerne les agents du
Conseil de l'Europe lorsqu'il y avait
des obstacles ou des des problèmes de
déontologie et de responsabilité qui se
posait mon rôle consistait à conseiller
aux Secrétaire Général du Conseil de
l'Europe les mesures disciplinaires
qu'il convenait de prendre et lorsque
les agents introduisaient des recours à
l'encontre de ces mesures disciplinaires
il m'appartenait de défendre le
Secrétaire Général du Conseil de
l'Europe dans la même période je suis
resté en contact avec les questions de
justice puisque j'ai été le secrétaire
de la Conférence des ministres européens
de la justice du Conseil de l'Europe et
j'ai également organisé en 2004 le
bicentenaire du Code civil au plan
européen avec Madame Simone Veil comme
rapporteur général
en 2007 le président Jean-Paul Costa qui
est comme vous le savez le premier
président français de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme depuis René Cassin
m'a appelé à ses côtés pour diriger son
cabinet ce sont les fonctions que
j'exerce toujours aujourd'hui 16 ans
plus tard mais avec d'autres présidents
puisque six présidents ont succédé à
Jean-Paul Costa un Britannique un
Italien à luxembourgeois en islandais un
Grec et actuellement une Irlandaise la
première femme présidente de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et ils
m'ont fait l'honneur de me conserver
alors côté mon rôle n'est pas un rôle
judiciaire au sein de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme mais elle a la
demande de Jean-Paul Costa j'ai mis en
oeuvre ce qu'il appelait la diplomatie
judiciaire c'est-à-dire mettre en
permanence la cour en relation avec les
acteurs de la vie des démocratique
d'abord évidemment les cours supérieures
qui travaillent
dans chaque État membre au service de
l'État de droit
ses cours supérieurs le président Costa
et c'est ce que je me suis efforcé
depuis avec lui et avec ses successeurs
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
a des relations constantes avec ses
cours et cela se fait au moyen de
rencontre soit dans les pays eux-mêmes
soit lorsque ces cours supérieures se
déplacent à la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
la conception qui est celle de la Cour
n'est pas une conception pyramidale on
est passé pour reprendre les termes de
François host de la pyramide au réseau
et les cours supérieurs travaillent avec
la Cour européenne droit de l'homme un
peu comme un mot les mobiles de Calder
pour reprendre l'expression de l'ancien
président de la Cour constitutionnelle
de karlsruh Andreas foscool
ce rapport avec les cours
supérieurs ont abouti en 2015 à la
création d'un réseau qui a pu être créé
grâce aux conseils d'État français et à
la Cour de cassation un réseau des cours
supérieurs qui crée initialement avec
deux cours rassemble aujourd'hui plus de
100 juridictions en provenance de la
quasi-totalité des États membres du
Conseil de l'Europe et je crois qu'à cet
égard c'est un réseau unique au monde
mais le rapport de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme dans le cadre de
cette de ces relations ne se limite pas
au cours supérieur il y a aussi des
relations avec les avocats et c'est
évidemment fondamental car les avocats
font vivre la Convention européenne des
droits de l'homme et sans les avocats il
n'y a tout simplement pas de convention
dans les juridictions il y a les
organisations non gouvernementales très
actives dans ce domaine et il y a les
parlements et c'est un point tout à fait
essentiel sur lequel je voudrais
insister en effet lorsque j'organise les
activités du président de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et
notamment ses missions dans les pays
membres du Conseil de l'Europe il y a
toujours des rencontres avec les
parlementaires cela est fonda général et
comme vous le savez monsieur le
Président il n'est pas anodin de
rappeler que la première visite
officielle de la nouvelle présidente de
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
elle l'a réservé à cette maison au
Parlement français à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat et c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui est tout à
fait volontaire car les relations avec
les parlements sont essentiels comme
vous le savez Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires les sénateurs vous le
savez ce sont les parlementaires qui
élisent les juges de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et la délégation
parlementaire française comprend des
sénateurs qui sont particulièrement
actifs dans le cadre de cette mission
en outre le Parlement joue un rôle que
vous connaissez bien pour l'exécution
des arrêts de la Cour lorsqu'il y a lieu
d'amender les lois à la suite d'un arrêt
de la Cour les questions d'éthique sont
au cœur de l'activité du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et dans le
cadre de ces fonctions d'éthique à
certains nombres de mesure ont été
adoptées comme vous le savez le CSM
adopte un recueil des obligations
déontologiques des magistrats qui a été
adopté en 2010 et réactualisé en 2019 et
bien la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a emprunté la même voie puisque
dès 2008 elle s'est dotée et j'ai
participé de la de la l'élaboration et
de l'adoption d'une résolution sur
l'éthique judiciaire et de la même
manière que le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature actualisé son recueil en
2019 et bien la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme a amendé sa résolution
en 2021
je suis également en charge de la
communication de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et à cet égard je suis
extrêmement sensibilisé aux questions de
communication car il est important que
le justiciable puisse avoir connaissance
des arrêts des juridictions et de la
manière la plus lisible qui soit
j'observe que les juridictions
supérieures françaises que ce soit le
Conseil d'État ou la Cour de cassation
ont beaucoup amélioré leur communication
et qu'aujourd'hui on trouve notamment
sur les comptes Twitter de ces
institutions et bien des informations
très précises sur la jurisprudence des
questions réponses également qui
permettent de bien comprendre les arrêts
qui sont rendus c'est également les
débats la démarche que j'ai adopté à la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
je crois qu'il est extrêmement important
pour que le justiciable et connaissances
qu'ils comprennent la jurisprudence que
la communication des juridictions et
aussi celle du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature soit aussi complète que
possible
comme vous le savez également le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature est engagée
dans un réseau le réseau européen des
conseils de justice la participation à
ce réseau européen est évidemment
importante et mon expérience
internationale pourra peut-être être
utile à ce réseau je reviens à l'instant
sur la question de la relation avec les
parlements pour rappeler que les
commissions des lois aussi bien de
l'Assemblée nationale que du Sénat à
l'époque présidé par Monsieur le
Président sueur sont venus à la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et pour
un échange qui je crois avait été très
fructueux il y a déjà une dizaine
d'années
en outre je dois dire que l'un des
aspects je l'ai signaler au début de mon
propos liminaire du rôle du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature c'est son
rôle de ressources humaines de la
magistrature et bien ce rôle ne met pas
inconnu puisque depuis maintenant une
quinzaine d'années je suis un chef de
service je gère je participe à des jurys
de recrutement à l'intérieur de
l'organisation
lors de l'arrivée de nouveaux agents et
aussi en promotion lorsque des agents
souhaitent être promus donc l'expérience
en matière de ressources humaines est
une expérience qui ne m'est pas inconnue
et notamment pour tout ce qui concerne
les retours aux candidats malheureux ce
qui est parfois une expérience qui doit
être faite je sais que le CSM le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature procède
également de la même manière
une des propositions qui est contenue
dans le rapport des états généraux de la
justice et qui est une disposition une
proposition intéressante je dirais même
très intéressante c'est l'évaluation à
360 degrés qui concernerait les
magistrats qui ne sont pas évalués c'est
à dire principalement les plus hauts
magistrats cette méthode d'évaluation à
360 degrés existe depuis déjà assez
longtemps au Conseil de l'Europe et j'ai
été à plusieurs reprises soit un évalué
soit un évaluateur et je pourrais à cet
égard apporter mon expérience au Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature si vous me
jugez digne d'en faire partie je
voudrais également parler d'un autre
aspect qui est contenu dans le rapport
des États généraux c'est l'équipe autour
du juge c'est une idée très importante
et je dirais que ce n'est pas une idée
nouvelle puisque déjà je crois dans le
rapport de Monsieur Hubert Hennel que
beaucoup d'entre vous ont connu et de du
sénateur Arthuis elle était contenue
mais en tout cas le Conseil supérieur le
comité des États généraux la utilise à
son compte et je crois qu'effectivement
elle est une idée importante et une voix
qui pourrait permettre de
finalement d'aider les juges dans le la
situation qu'il a l'heure actuellement
où on parle d'une grande solitude et
c'est ce qui ressort du rapport du
Comité des États généraux et je pense
que l'équipe autour du juge est
certainement une des solutions qui
pourraient être mise en oeuvre au cours
des cinq prochaines années et je crois
qu'un certain nombre de recrutements
notamment des juristes assistants et
prévu à cet effet la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme elle fonctionne déjà
avec ce système de l'équipe autour du
juge et je peux mesurer l'importance que
cela représente pour les 46 juges de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme je
ne serai pas complet si je ne
mentionnais pas mes relations avec
l'École nationale de la magistrature où
j'ai été formé il y a 40 ans et qui
évidemment est une un outil important
dans la déontologie je crois
qu'effectivement dans tout ce qui est
déontologie formation à la déontologie
des auditeurs de justice dès le premier
jour de leur formation mais aussi
formation à la déontologie des
magistrats tout au long de leur carrière
et notamment à l'occasion de leur
changement de fonction car les questions
des logique ne sont pas forcément les
mêmes selon les fonctions que l'on va
exercer l'École nationale de la
magistrature est un outil essentiel pour
renforcer la déontologie
en conclusion je voudrais dire que
depuis quelques années on voit évoluer
la jurisprudence de la Cour et notamment
pour tout ce qui concerne l'indépendance
de la justice en effet il existe
aujourd'hui un contentieux qui est de
plus en plus important qui n'existait
pas il y a 15 ou 20 ans où l'on voit
dans certains pays des atteintes à
l'indépendance de la justice ces
atteintes elles se traduisent souvent
par la révocation de membres de conseils
de justice et comme vous le savez il y a
des affaires importantes qui concernent
la Hongrie et la Pologne actuellement
une centaine d'affaires une centaine
d'affaires ce qui n'est pas négligeable
concerne la Pologne du point de vue de
des réformes judiciaires cela me fait
prendre conscience de l'importance que
présente un organe tel que le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature pour la
garantie de l'État de droit si vous
confirmez cette proposition nomination
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
bien ce serait pour moi l'aboutissement
d'une carrière qui a été entièrement
consacrée à la justice d'abord à la
nationale interne et depuis maintenant
30 ans à la justice internationale je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur Titien alors y a-t-il des
questions Monsieur Philippe
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
je vous remercie monsieur de votre
exposé
une question très simple
de votre point de vue
le Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
peut-il prendre des positions publiques
sur la politique judiciaire du
gouvernement et sur les textes
législatifs qui la concernent qui sont
soumis au Parlement
merci je peux compléter la question les
états généraux de la justice préconisent
notamment dans la réforme du CSM la
possibilité que celui-ci puisse être
entendu sur le budget de la justice par
les parlementaires
c'est une question qui ne se fait pas
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
j'en perçois merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur pour vous expliquer
je vois que vous êtes extrêmement bien
placé pour mesurer combien il est
quelque peu préjudiciable que la France
soit régulièrement condamné par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme au
motif que le parquet ne bénéficierait
pas des qualités qui selon elle sont
nécessaires à fonder son indépendance
vous n'ignorez pas que un texte a été
voté à cet égard dans les mêmes termes
par l'Assemblée nationale et par le
Sénat
et il peut paraître paradoxal que cette
question reste en suspens alors qu'il y
a eu ce texte d'adopter par les deux
assemblées peut-être d'ailleurs est-ce
une c'est une parenthèse y a-t-il
toujours l'idée qu'il faut faire une
grande réforme constitutionnelle globale
ce qui à mon avis est pratiquement
impossible ce qui ou difficile très
difficile ce qui empêche de faire des
réformes constitutionnelles partiel sur
des sujets sur lesquels il serait
possible d'obtenir la majorité des trois
cinquièmes requises dont je voulais vous
demander quel est votre sentiment par
rapport à cette question de la réforme
qui paraît qui apparaît à beaucoup
d'entre nous comme nécessaire du statut
du parquet
merci monsieur Jean-Yves Leconte puis
ensuite monsieur Richard
oui
contenu de votre rôle actuel j'ai envie
de vous poser une question d'actualité
sur ce que nous sur les sujets sur
lequel nous travaillons ici sur ce que
vous pensez et l'opportunité de qui est
dans les traités européens de l'adhésion
de l'Union européenne à la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
et de des conditions que la CGE a posé à
cette adhésion
[Musique]
c'est Monsieur Richard
oui je pense que votre l'expérience que
vous avez très bien décrite vous place
en position d'être sans doute le
meilleur comparatif en matière de statut
de la magistrature en Europe
et donc comme ça un peu à
ce que vous voyez dans le statut
dans les statuts que vous pouvez
comparer
des magistratures nationales
au sein du Conseil de l'Europe un
exemple d'amélioration
pour être
débattue à propos du statut de la
magistrature française
ou au contraire est-ce que vous voyez un
sujet sur lequel nous serions notre
statue nationale de statut de 58
représenterait un exemple qui n'est pas
assez suivi par les autres magistratures
autre question dans le prolongement de
la question de Monsieur Richard
il est envisagé de recruter plus de 1500
magistrats supplémentaires assez
rapidement pour remettre l'institution
judiciaire à Flo si je puis dire 20% du
corps aujourd'hui est composé de
personnes venues de l'extérieur
c'est-à-dire en dehors de lainem comment
imaginez-vous ce recrutement de ces 1500
magistrats supplémentaires
singulièrement à l'égard de ceux qui
pourraient intégrer via en dehors de
l'ONEM en tous les cas on vient un
parcours différent notamment pour le
maintien de la qualité
je vous laisse la parole
je vous remercie monsieur le président
la première question est celle de
Monsieur le Sénateur bas concernant le
la possibilité pour le Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature de prendre position
sur des questions concernant la justice
je crois qu'il le fait déjà et que
actuellement au travers de communiquer
il prend position sur des sujets
d'intérêt général des sujets qui
concernent précisément la justice il le
fait de manière extrêmement prudente et
il n'intervient pas à tout moment ce qui
me semble important et
vous avez complété cette question
monsieur le Président par la question
relative au budget ce qui me semble
important c'est que les modalités
d'expression du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature se fasse dans un forum de
dialogue d'échanges et de discussions le
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature de
par ses missions et notamment de par sa
connaissance des territoires par le fait
qu'il se rendent dans des juridictions
dans des cours et dans des tribunaux
à connaissance déjà du fonctionnement de
la justice sur le terrain et je pense
que notamment dans le cadre de
Commission comme la commission des lois
il pourrait y avoir un très grand
intérêt à ce que des échanges se fassent
avec le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature notamment par exemple à
l'occasion de la publication du rapport
annuel d'activités du Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature qui je ne sais pas si
cela se fait mais de cela devrait
pouvoir se faire qu'il y ait un échange
en tout cas entre la commission des lois
et le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature la pratique actuelle qui
est suivie par le Conseil super de la
magistrature c'est-à-dire des prises de
position ponctuelle à l'occasion de tel
ou tel événement me paraît une pratique
satisfaisante et qui devrait être
poursuivi lorsque évidemment les
intérêts de la justice l'exigent
monsieur le sénateur sueur concernant le
parquet c'est un vieux débat et je me
souviens que déjà vous aviez exprimé des
préoccupations à cet égard lorsque vous
étiez venu à la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme il y a 10 ans
les préoccupations subsistent
effectivement alors je crois qu'il faut
rappeler que lorsque la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme a condamné la
France ça n'était pas
principalement en raison du statut du
parquet mais c'était en raison du rôle
du parquet dans le cadre des procédures
judiciaires et du fait que le parquet
conservait dans le cadre d'une procédure
pénale même s'il était indépendant il
n'était pas impartial puisqu'il était
une partie poursuivante et donc il ne
pouvait pas être considéré comme
impartial et c'est ce qui est le rôle du
parquet de poursuivre les infractions
pénales et donc je crois que en ce qui
concerne cette réforme si elle
intervient un jour en tout état de cause
il y a un rôle du parquet comme
poursuivant qui subsisterait et la
personne qui est arrêtée placé en garde
à vue elle devrait être de toute façon
en tout état de cause être présenté
devant un juge un juge indépendant et
impartial
et cela
ne conduit à répondre à monsieur le
sénateur Richard parce que les deux
questions finalement sont liées les
améliorations possibles d'abord je crois
que le statut de la magistrature en
France est protecteur et que nous
n'avons pas et en tout cas la France n'a
pas à rougi de son statut les
améliorations elles sont toujours
possibles et c'est l'oeuvre du
législateur du constituant précisément
de procéder à ces améliorations c'est
vous qui améliorez le fonctionnement des
institutions mais je pense que le statut
des magistrats en France est un statut
qui est le résultat le fruit d'une
évolution au long des ans et que
finalement aujourd'hui notamment la
composition du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature offre toutes les garanties
mais les améliorations et c'est là que
je reviens à l'une des autres questions
qui m'a été posée elle pourrait se faire
par exemple en donnant aux conseils
supérieur de la magistrature le pouvoir
d'émettre un avis conforme pour les
nominations des magistrats du je sais
que cela correspond à la pratique et que
dans la réalité des faits les gardent
des os sans successifs ne se sont
finalement pas écartés des des
décisions qui ont été prises par le CSM
en se ralliant à leur s'il y avait des
avis non conformes qui d'ailleurs sont
assez rares mais il me semble que mettre
le droit en accord avec la pratique
consiste constituerait une amélioration
et c'est ainsi que je souhaite répondre
à votre question
monsieur le sénateur le compte vous
m'avez posé une question qui n'est pas
facile qui concerne l'adhésion de
l'Union européenne à la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients
mais là pour moi ce que
ce que cela peut représenter comme
avantage en tout cas c'est le fait de
donner aux justiciable parce que c'est
pour lui finalement que ce type de
mesure doit être fait une meilleure
compréhension des systèmes européens et
finalement de soumettre à la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme les
décisions qui sont les décisions prises
par les institutions de leur de l'Union
européenne lorsqu'elles sont en
contradiction avec des droits de l'homme
mais je pense qu'il faut aussi cette ce
processus d'adhésion et ce processus de
négociation se poursuit il faut prendre
le temps de bien vérifier les modalités
notamment les modalités pratiques de
mise en œuvre par rapport à toute une
série de questions qui se posent et
notamment pour les questions de sécurité
évidemment donc je crois que c'est un
sujet qui est délicat et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle comme
vous le savez ce n'est pas un projet
nouveau cela fait à peu près 40 ans que
ce projet est discuté et il y a eu bien
avant la vie de la Cour de justice le
dernier avis 2013 il y avait eu des avis
plus anciens donc c'est c'est bien la
preuve que c'est un sujet qu'il faut
manier avec beaucoup de prudence et qui
devra se faire au terme de négociation
extrêmement compliquée d'autant plus que
comme vous le savez le change
géographique du Conseil de l'Europe
n'est pas le même que celui de l'Union
européenne et ce sont évidemment des
points qui doivent être
qui doivent être pris en considération
que j'ai répondu à toutes les questions
ah oui alors sur les recrutements alors
sur les recrutements on entre dans une
période extrêmement importante puisque
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président il va y avoir beaucoup de
recrutements et tous ces recrutements ne
pourront pas être des recrutements que
je qualifierai de classiques d'étudiants
qui vont passer le concours d'entrée à
l'ENM il va falloir faire appel à des
recrutements latéraux je pense
personnellement que c'est une bonne
chose et que c'est un moyen d'ouvrir la
magistrature en faisant appel à des
talents nouveaux différentes des avocats
bien entendu des professeurs
d'université des maîtres de conférence
on parle beaucoup du fait qu'il y ait de
moins en moins de civilistes et qu'il y
a une pénurie de civiliste et bien je
suis convaincu que les avocats et les
mettent de conférence vont apporter
précisément leurs compétences en matière
civile à la magistrature et je suis
résolument en faveur de ces recrutements
latéraux je pense que que c'est
extrêmement important on fait proche
parfois la magistrature d'être entre soi
et bien justement il faut ouvrir les
portes de la magistrature à tous ceux
qui veulent apporter leur concours à
l'oeuvre de justice maintenant la
question de la formation est essentielle
cela ne veut pas dire en recrutant plus
largement que l'on ne forme pas car il y
a bien sûr on a parlé de déontologie
toute une série de mesures qu'il faudra
faire connaître le à ces nouveaux
magistrats et là l'École nationale de la
magistrature va être confronté à un défi
un défi qui va être celui de former les
magistrats qui passent par le premier ou
le second concours mais aussi tous ces
magistrats qui vont arriver par des
voies latérales en tout état de cause la
formation est notamment la formation à
la déontologie doit rester absolument
crucial pour ces recrutements qui vont
intervenir au cours des cinq prochaines
années voilà ce que je crois en tout cas
qui peut permettre de donner finalement
cet oxygène au magistrats dont ils ont
tellement besoin dans la situation
actuelle
j'aimerais peut-être une question
puisque vous évoquez la déontologie le
président de la République avait demandé
au Conseil Supérieur un rapport sur la
responsabilité des magistrats ce rapport
a été rendu
comment vous est-ce que vous comment
vous apprendez est-ce que vous apprendez
vous appréhendez déjà
cette notion de responsabilité de
magistrat d'une plus grande j'ai des
presque dire pas transparence le terme
n'est pas exact mais en tous les cas une
façon d'appréhender cette problématique
qui fait sujet en tout cas qui fait
critique
c'est une question centrale c'est
peut-être la question la plus
essentielle parce qu'au fond nos
concitoyens doivent avoir la conviction
que les magistrats compte tenu de leur
pouvoir et de leur indépendance ont
aussi un sens aigu de leur
responsabilité à cet égard je crois que
les chiffres contrairement à ce que
parfois les publics pensent sont plutôt
rassurants il y a de plus en plus de
poursuites disciplinaires cela montre
que le CSM le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature prend sa mission très à
coeur j'ajoute que les audiences
disciplinaires du Conseil supérieur de
la magistrature sont publiques et que
les Français peuvent avoir accès à ces
audiences ce qui me paraît être un
progrès considérable et donc
je crois qu'il faut poursuivre dans
cette voie cette voie de transparence
avec peut-être aussi d'autres
possibilités notamment de donner des
c'est ce qui avait été suggéré
d'ailleurs dans la réponse du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature à la
demande du président de la public de
donner la possibilité à la commission
d'admission des requêtes de jouer un
rôle en matière d'alerte sur les
comportements tangents c'est à dire les
comportements qui ne sont pas
constitutifs d'une faute disciplinaire
mais qui sont des comportements qui
peuvent
être en quelque sorte des précurseurs
des fautes disciplinaires les attitudes
qui ne sont que je qualifierai d'infras
disciplinaire mais là il y a un rôle du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature qui
est un rôle d'alerte je crois aussi que
les premiers présidents des grosses
d'appels que les présidents des
tribunaux judiciaires ont un rôle
déterminant l'entretien desontologiques
est aussi quelque chose de capital et
d'ailleurs cela me permet de compléter
la réponse que j'avais faite à monsieur
le sénateur Richard je crois que la
question de l'entretien déontologique
fait partie de ce qui existe en France
et qui n'existe pas dans tous les les
États membres c'est certainement un
point sur lequel nous pouvons inspirer
d'autres d'autres pratiques merci
monsieur le Président merci beaucoup
monsieur s'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions il me reste à vous remercier
pour votre présence ce matin elle est
réponses que vous avez apportées aux
questions des différents collègues nous
allons voter immédiatement pour vous
informer mais nous attendrons 12h30 pour
dépouiller pour le faire en même temps
que l'Assemblée nationale
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
et je remercie également tous les
sénatrices et tous les sénateurs qui ont
bien voulu m'écouter ce matin merci à
vous
à l'instant madame Guigou même la
ministre qui est donc proposé par le
Président de la République pour siéger
au sein du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
madame dans quelques instants monsieur
je vais vous laisser la parole
durant ensuite sans doute des questions
posées par l'ensemble des collègues et
nous avons environ 45 minutes
qui est le temps de votre audition et
des réponses aux questions je rappelle
que il y aura un vote à bulletin secret
immédiatement après votre audition et
que le dépouillement de celui-ci aura
lieu qu'à 12h30 car confinement au
disposition de l'article 13 de la
Constitution nous devons dépouiller en
même temps que l'Assemblée nationale et
nous avons convenu avec la sommet
national qui se dépouillement se ferait
à 12h30 voilà les choses sont ainsi
organisées et bien écoutez je vous
laisse immédiatement la parole
pardon excusez-moi que votre édition est
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat donc elle a donc un
caractère public et que préalablement
avant votre venue nous avons fait un
rapport sur l'ensemble des candidats à
l'ensemble de la commission pour que les
choses soient parfaitement claires
merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
d'avoir je suis très honorée de
retrouver devant votre commission des
Lois que j'ai beaucoup fréquenté à
certains moments et dont je ne garde de
dire que de très bons souvenirs parce
que l'expertise
juridique est ici exceptionnelle
voilà je rendais hommage à l'expertise
juridique de la de la commission des
lois alors
évidemment je vais je vais vous dire en
quoi il me semble à moi c'est à vous
d'en juger évidemment quoi mon parcours
peut-être
utile pour le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature peut-être aussi comment je
compte aborder mes fonctions et ce que
je comprends des enjeux
actuels et à venir pour cette
institution aussi importante pour l'État
de droit puisque elle assiste le
Président de la République sur
l'indépendance de la magistrature et
quelle garantie au fond et la séparation
des pouvoirs et l'équilibre entre eux du
côté de la magistrature et bien sûr
l'indépendance de la magistrature
alors je veux souligner dans mon
parcours d'abord que
d'abord que
tout tout mon parcours a été consacré au
service public et au service de
l'intérêt général
je j'ai été à la fois jeune
fonctionnaire pendant 8 ans puis j'ai
exercé des fonctions de cabinet
ministériels et présidentielles
au cabinet Jacques Delors puis à la
présidence de la République et puis
j'ai eu le privilège d'être nommé au
gouvernement en 1990 là je suis j'ai
exercé des responsabilités politiques
directes avec un travail intense avec
leur parlement je me souviens en
particulier
du travail que
j'ai conduit ici avec votre commission
des Lois dans laquelle le sénateur passe
quoi joue un rôle absolument éminent
et nous avons eu quelques discussions
qui ont souvent été très vives sur à
propos de la Convention de Schengen et
de sa ratification même chose évidemment
pour la ratification du traité d'Union
Européenne en 1992 mais c'était toujours
toujours les discussions d'un très très
bon niveau avec le souci de trouver pour
notre République la meilleure solution
possible dans un contexte évidemment qui
était celui dans ces années là d'un
bouleversement en Europe
puisque nous venions
d'accepter l'unification de l'Allemagne
[Musique]
que les pays d'Europe centrale et
orientale se libérer de la tutelle
soviétique et que donc il fallait
tout en étant et c'était le choix qui
avait fait notre pays qu'il sera
consolidé après être dans l'Union
européenne évidemment à la fois défendre
nos intérêts nationaux et faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent coïncider en tout cas
être articulé avec les
intérêts aussi des autres États membres
alors dans mes fonctions antérieures
j'avais comme j'avais été chargé par le
Président de la République François
Mitterrand de diriger le service de
service général les de l'Europe à la
fois de l'Union européenne qui ne
s'appelait pas encore comme ça à
l'époque et aussi des pays de l'Europe
de l'Est j'avais acquis des compétences
je dirais de gestion d'équipe
et surtout j'avais approché de très très
près les questions juridiques alors que
ma formation intérieure était plutôt
économique financière et monétaire parce
que
omgae service général des activités
européennes services interministériel
qui entre 1985 et 1990 j'ai donc dirigé
mais qui pendant deux ans a exercé ses
activités en période de cohabitation
entre le président Mitterrand et le
Premier ministre Chirac
là nous étions affrontés non seulement
la conciliation des intérêts entre ces
deux têtes de l'agriculture mais aussi
tous les jours
à concilier notre droit national avec le
droit européen tous les jours nous nous
interrogions sur les projets de
directive ou de règlement que nous
envoyait la Commission européenne pour
voir si c'était si la France devait ou
pas d'ailleurs les accepter et ce que
voudrait dire quel serait les
conséquences pour notre droit interne
donc je veux dire que là pendant 5 ans
ma formation au droit dans tous les
secteurs de la vie publique parce que
j'essaie d'agriculture de pêche de
transport d'environnement de questions
sociales
a été
en tout cas assez intense
au ministère des Affaires européennes
il y avait
j'ai appris ce qui était le travail avec
le Parlement je n'avais jamais été élu
et là j'ai vu
à quel point il était très très
important de suivre en effet de très
près le travail notamment dans les dans
les commissions
parce que il est important d'avoir des
convictions c'est sûr mais peut-être
utile quelquefois de se rendre aux
convictions des autres alors
j'ai bien sûr
à ce moment là
compris que plus que jamais l'état de
droit
en Europe et dans notre pays était
important et que
tous ces
pays d'Europe centrale et orientale qui
allait nous rejoindre bientôt nous
avions besoin de leur rappeler à quel
point nos droits et libertés
fondamentales devaient être respectée
par eux jusqu'à à la fin des années 90
jusqu'à l'heure adhésion on pensait que
ça allait de soi on n'éprouvait pas
d'ailleurs le besoin de modifier nos
droits les préambules les traités et
comme j'ai eu la chance avec un collègue
allemand de désigné par le Parlement
européen élu par le Parlement européen
pour représenter
représenter le Parlement européen
négociation du traité d'Amsterdam qui
sera conclure en 1997 nous avons réécrit
la Charte des droits fondamentaux pour
avec l'idée qu'il fallait effectivement
préciser certaines choses notamment tout
le dispositif de non discrimination dont
nous avons donné une définition élargie
je suis
j'ai été élu pour la première fois dans
une élection nationale législative en
1997 mais je n'ai pas siéger puisque
j'ai été appelé au gouvernement
immédiatement comme garde des sceaux là
évidemment était confronté tous les
jours à des questions de droit que
j'avais été un peu abordés mais surtout
j'ai
pris l'engagement immédiatement
après
des épisodes pour certains
rocambolesques en tout cas très navrant
qui avait conduit l'exécutif à
s'immiscer dans les questions de
dossiers individuels de la justice j'ai
pris immédiatement l'engagement de ne
jamais intervenir ne jamais donner
d'instructions au procureur dans les
dossiers individuels et de toujours me
conformer à l'avis donné par le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature sur les
nominations et je n'ai jamais dérogé à
cette règle pendant toute la durée de ce
ministère
j'ai aussi engagé une réforme qui a
abouti en 1999 qui a été voté dans les
mêmes termes par l'Assemblée nationale
et votre assemblée et qui consistait
précisément aggraver dans la
Constitution les engagements et les
pratiques que nous avions que j'avais
avec mon cabinet et l'administration que
je dirigeais parce que j'avais vérifié
que notamment à la direction des
affaires criminelles et des grâces tout
le monde suivrait ce
cet engagement que nous avions donc mis
en pratique cette réforme depuis bloquée
maintenant depuis 44 ans
24 ans pardon j'exagère là quand même
même si des progrès ont été faits par
exemple avec la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 qui a
opportunément retiré au président de la
République et au garde des sceaux la
présidence et la vice-présidence du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature ou
encore et donner d'ailleurs aux citoyens
la possibilité de faire appel
lorsqu'il s'estime victime d'une d'une
absence de partialité d'un partialité
d'un magistrat mais aussi par la loi de
loi de 2013 qui a écrit dans la loi que
les instructions individuelles au
procureur étaient désormais proscrite
par la loi d'ailleurs il me semble que
depuis une quinzaine d'années
cette ceci a même avant la loi de 2013 a
été a été respectée
alors
j'ai ensuite
pendant dans ce ministère nous avons
fait beaucoup beaucoup d'autres choses
évidemment
nous avons abordé des questions aussi
aussi diverses que
d'avoir la réforme du code de procédure
pénale avec la réécriture de l'article
préliminaire mais la présomption
d'innocence au premier rang de toutes
les règles qui doivent être respectées
dans toute la procédure
présomption d'innocence et droits des
victimes je le souligne c'est le titre
de la loi même si on oublie souvent le
second bien sûr l'accès aux droits
l'aide juridictionnelle la tension
portée
à l'amélioration concrète des conditions
de détention
les moyens
supplémentaires importants donnés à la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
et aussi des réformes de sociétés comme
le pacs ou la parité
après ce ministère j'avais dans ce
ministère noué des relations de travail
étroites avec le ministère des affaires
sociales que j'ai ensuite dirigé pendant
presque deux ans
notamment sur la question de la
protection des enfants victimes de
d'actes de violence et nous avons
continué à mettre en place les unités de
pédiatriques
qui faisait en sorte que l'on protégeait
les enfants victimes de violence
lorsqu'ils devaient venir devant des
enquêteurs ou devant des juges
voilà par la suite j'ai été élu à
l'Assemblée nationale pendant réélu
puisque j'avais déjà été lui en
en 1997 j'ai été élu pendant trois
législatures d'affilée en
Seine-Saint-Denis
département évidemment qui concentre
beaucoup de
pauvreté et je dois dire que dans toute
cette expérience il m'a semblé que ce
qu'était le plus important c'était
d'essayer d'apprendre de celles et ceux
qui n'avaient pas les mêmes fonctions
que celles qu'on exerçait j'ai notamment
appris à quel point il était le rôle des
élus locaux
était absolument crucial et je considère
d'ailleurs que à l'École nationale de la
magistrature on devrait encore plus que
Sonel cas aujourd'hui faire en sorte que
les jeunes magistrats en particulier qui
n'ont pas encore d'expérience
professionnelle puisse multiplier les
stages non seulement dans les
administrations centrales mais aussi
dans les administrations
locales pour se faire une idée de du
fait que il n'y a pas que la
connaissance du droit elle est
essentielle mais il y a la connaissance
de la vie tout simplement et de la
société merci beaucoup
merci Madame
il y a donc un salon de collègues qui
souhaite poser des questions le premier
d'entre nous et monsieur Jean-Yves
Leconte
oui merci monsieur le Président je vais
poser une question qui est un peu dans
les esprit que celle de Jean-Pierre
soeur tout à l'heure vous avez madame la
ministre participé à une majorité où
nous avons voté
un projet de loi constitutionnel qui
renforce l'indépendance du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
vous avez rappelé vos engagements
européens donc vous savez combien c'est
important que le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature évolue combien la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme nous là
nous la rappeler ce besoin
dès lors que
au président de la République vous
propose à une nomination Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature sans
réforme
lui avez-vous posé la question de savoir
si finalement il envisageait cette
réforme ou pas
et est-ce que vous considérez que
finalement le CSM dans sa
composition et son fonctionnement actuel
peut permettre
de répondre aux exigences européennes
merci Monsieur le conte une demande de
parole de Monsieur Alain Marc merci
Président Madame l'affaire du mur des
cons a considérablement dégradé l'image
de la magistrature la vie rendu juste
après par le CSM à ce moment-là était un
gros que cette affaire-là était une
affaire strictement syndicale
ce qui pour les gens qui sont peu au
fait du monde de judiciaire accentue la
méfiance à accentuer la méfiance encore
parce que cette affaire est toujours
présente dans les dans les consciences à
l'égard des magistrats et j'en suis moi
le premier désolé
comptez-vous si vous faites partie du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
faire en sorte que la déontologie soit
plus présente dans la formation des
magistrats mais aussi dans l'exercice de
leur fonction et ce par quel moyen
je me permettrais madame de prolonger la
question de Monsieur Lamarque sur le
fait que le Président de la République
avait demandé au Conseil Supérieur
magistrature une analyse sur la
responsabilité éventuelle des magistrats
que ce rapport a été rendu qu'elle
appréhension avez-vous de du rapport
fait par le Conseil supérieur
administrature et quel est votre
intention à cet égard c'est très lié
effectivement à l'aspect déontologie
mais c'est également aussi lié au niveau
de
notre façon aux conditions dans
lesquelles le recrutement des 1500
magistrats supplémentaires annoncés par
le garde des sceaux va se mettre en
place singulièrement à l'égard de ceux
qui n'ont pas fait la magie l'école
nationale administrature qui viennent
d'autres horizons à la fois pour en
garder le niveau juridique c'est une
chose mais également l'appréhension
déontologique de la profession de
magistrat
pas d'autres questions
madame vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
si vous confirmez ma nomination
je rentrerai dans le Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature tel qu'il est
ils sont une référence la Constitution
maintenant dans ces pratiques le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature a déjà
beaucoup évolué et il ne sait pas
interdit de donner son opinion ses avis
sur de possibles réforme futures
donc je participerai avec intérêt à ce
genre de réflexion mais il appartient
évidemment à la représentation nationale
de décider ou pas des réformes ce que ce
qu'il me semble c'est que
il est important que le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
sans empiéter sur les prérogatives du
Parlement
c'est-à-dire sans se saisir d'office en
dehors des cas qui sont prévus par la
Constitution
donc que le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature continue l'évolution qu'il
a
abordé et qui consiste à communiquer
à produire des
des avis sur son site à communiquer sur
ses activités je crois que cette
organe si essentiel au bon
fonctionnement de
nos institutions n'est pas suffisamment
connu et qu'il doit en particulier
communiquer et faire savoir davantage
aux citoyens
quelle est la véritable signification de
ce de ce droit de plainte des citoyens
auprès du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
se plainte elle se multiplie parce que
notre justice est de plus en plus décrié
comme d'ailleurs toutes les institutions
de la République alors même qu'on fait
appel à elle de plus en plus il y a une
judiciarisation de la vie
publique qui est mon avis à certains
égards préoccupantes mais qui montre
paradoxalement que tout en décriant la
justice le concitoyens font appel et ont
conscience que il faut faire appel donc
là la pédagogie l'information sur ce
qu'est la justice comment elle
fonctionne la participation des citoyens
a
à nos tribunaux doit vraiment être
quelque chose d'important car l'exemple
des cours d'assises nous montre que
quand des citoyens qui sont arrivés avec
des idées il y a qu'à faire ceci il
faudrait qu'on fasse cela
quand il ressortent on mieux compris ce
qui se passe alors je moi je viens de
vous dire que j'espère que la réforme
qui est bloquée depuis maintenant
presque 24 ans de la Constitution que
vous avez voté votre assemblée le Sénat
à votre Haute Assemblée à voter
voilà et qui est bloqué j'espère parce
que c'est un abcès de fixation qui est
préjudiciable qui empoisonne beaucoup du
fonctionnement de la justice qui
alimente beaucoup la défiance des
citoyens j'espère que cette réforme
constitutionnelle qui touche le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature pour être
votée
à Monsieur Monsieur Alain Marc
là oui vous avez raison ce genre de
d'épisode fâcheux
le
grand dit pas évidemment voilà
il faut maintenant j'espère que toutes
les toutes les leçons en auront été
tirées
les magistrats même
lorsqu'ils sont n'exerce pas leur
magistrature sont soumis selon les
règles de déontologie à un devoir de
réserves et à l'impératif de
dignité notamment dans leur vie
professionnelle comme dans leur vie
privée
c'est en tout cas ce que préconise leur
code de déontologie en dehors d'autres
vertus très importantes bien sûr qui
font de l'indépendance de la justice
l'impartialité
aussi la confiance des citoyens
l'intégrité évidemment qui s'impose
d'ailleurs à toute toute agent public
donc je crois que la déontologie est
extrêmement importante je me réjouis
qu'elle soit devenue une part importante
de l'activité du conseil et de
l'attention du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature à côté des nominations qui
qui absorbe le plus gros de l'énergie de
des membres du conseil mais parce que la
déontologie c'est de la prévention et
moi je crois plus à la prévention qu'à
en tout cas la sanction est nécessaire
lorsqu'elle doit être appliquée elle
doit l'être avec la plus grande rigueur
évidemment mais la déontologie est là
pour éviter justement que des fautes
relevant de la discipline des sanctions
disciplinaires soit commises et je me
réjouis du fait que le requin des
obligations des déontologiques
est constamment évolué au fur et à
mesure des évolutions de la société
j'espère si si vous confirmez ma
nomination pouvoir y contribuer
monsieur le Président vous avez évoqué
la la vie donnée par le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
à la demande du Président de la
République sur la responsabilité des
magistrats
c'est un texte évidemment très important
qui rappelle d'abord que les magistrats
ne bénéficient d'aucune impunité je
crois important de le rappeler
ils ne sont pas sont jugés lorsqu'il
commettent des actes de délinquance ou
de
ou des crimes comme les autres citoyens
mais est-ce que
en effet
ils sont toujours irréprochables dans
leur attitude parce que il y a
l'impartialité et l'image de
l'impartialité notamment que l'on peut
donner ce que les magistrats peuvent
donner à l'audience qui étaient tout
aussi importante pour la confiance des
citoyens dans la justice qui
malheureusement toutes les enquêtes nous
montrent à tendance à s'éroder gravement
et de plus en plus
or là la confiance dans la justice c'est
un des piliers de notre État de droit
et par conséquent il faut essayer de la
restaurer alors
c'est difficile parce que je disais il y
a un instant que toutes les institutions
dans d'autres sociétés telles qu'elle
évolue avec notamment sous l'influence
des réseaux sociaux mais avec le primat
de l'individualisme la perte du sens du
collectif le fait que il faille tout
tout de suite tout ça est très difficile
pour les institutions parce qu'on perd
de vue la
nécessité de regarder un moyen et à long
terme et que par ailleurs on a tendance
à se défier des règles collectives or
sans règles de droit sans État de droit
que ce soit à tous les niveaux
de la vie que ce soit aussi au niveau
national européen ou international sans
règles de droit il n'y a plus d'état de
droits c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a plus de
la possibilité de vivre en commun alors
malheureusement en l'observe au niveau
international il y a une grande vague de
contestation comme on dit du
multilatéralisme qui depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale avec la Charte
des Nations Unies fondées les droits
international et malheureusement avec
des manifestations de plus en plus
violentes on l'a vu pour le Capitole aux
États-Unis qui inspiré certainement les
partisans de Monsieur bolsonaro on le
voit
on le voit un peu partout on le voit
malheureusement au sein de l'Union
européenne avec des initiatives de
gouvernement d'État membres de l'Union
européenne en particulier de Pologne
mais aussi de Hongrie et là sont le
constat chez certains chez nous je crois
absolument cruciale de réagir contre
cela alors que peut faire le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature mais
d'abord il faut que les magistrats
soient exemplaires voilà c'est à dire
que lorsque ils ont des comportements y
compris les comportements qui ne
relèvent pas de sanctions disciplinaires
mais simplement des attitudes qui
peuvent être jugées offensantes par des
justiciersiables et bien je crois en
effet que il faut des rappels à l'ordre
le Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
a fait d'ailleurs quelques propositions
10 ans qu'il faudrait que dans certains
cas ce puisse être faire l'objet
d'avertissement inscrit au dossier que
l'avertissement reste non plus je crois
trois ans mais cinq ans dans les
dossiers que faire comprendre
justiciable que non seulement ils
peuvent avoir recours à au plaintes
auprès du Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature mais qu'ils peuvent aussi
écrire
de cours et de juridiction qui ont la
possibilité d'alerter tout de suite avec
menace d'avertissement les magistrats
qui ne seraient pas suffisamment
attentif voilà c'est pas suffisamment
attentif au justiciable j'ajoute que
l'augmentation des moyens
elle est
elle sera très bénéfique il faudra
simplement bien veiller à ce qu'elle
soit accompagnée par une modification
là aussi des méthodes de travail
former former les chefs de cours et de
juridiction à la gestion d'une équipe
qui heureusement va être mise d'après ce
que je comprends à leur disposition ça
ça prend pas du jour au lendemain voilà
et il suffit pas d'être un très bon
juriste ou un très bon magistrat pour
savoir mobiliser une équipe l'affaire
travailler lui demander ce qu'elle sait
faire la rendre heureuse dans son
travail pour qu'elle en rende le maximum
donc nous avons ce genre de défi je
crois que le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature d'ailleurs qui réclame
depuis longtemps qu'on évalue les chefs
de cours les chefs de juridiction et les
conseillers à la Cour de cassation fait
là de bonnes propositions
et j'ai lu cet avis
comme d'abord il insiste beaucoup sur la
déontologie en effet comme ayant le
souci en effet de mieux faire comprendre
ce qui était le métier de magistrat et
la fonction de juger et nous avons tous
je crois intérêt
parce que à respecter l'indépendance de
la magistrature à lui donner les moyens
d'être impartial parce que en retour
c'est comme cela que seront respectés
les prérogatives du Parlement que pour
ma part je respecte un finement compte
tenu de l'expérience que j'ai de leur
l'apport et en particulier je le
souligne du Sénat c'est pas par
flagornerie à votre égard j'ai pas dit
ça hier à l'Assemblée
de votre de votre oui c'est public alors
tout le monde l'entendra voilà je vous
remercie beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs pour
pour votre écoute question madame
Monsieur François bonhomme
en
dehors des pouvoirs de ces prograties en
terme de nomination le CSM des
progratives en termes de en termes
disciplinaire
considérez-vous que
lorsque le CSM statut comme conseil de
discipline concernant les magistrats du
siège
considérez-vous que il exerce
suffisamment cette prérogative en termes
de sanction disciplinaire et notamment
pour les cas d'insuffisance
professionnelle
question importante je crois qu'il y a
des progrès à faire
probablement d'abord au niveau des chefs
de juridiction
c'est pas facile pour un chef de
juridiction notamment dans les petites
tribunaux
d'alerter sur les insuffisances de
quelqu'un avec qui travaille tous les
jours
et qui d'ailleurs et qui d'ailleurs
probablement souffre beaucoup encore
maintenant
de l'insuffisance des moyens de
la de la le manque de temps
à accorder aux différents dossiers
ayant dit cela
je crois aussi que il faudrait que le
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
d'ailleurs lui-même souligne que
quelquefois
des viennent devant lui le cas de
magistrats dont on sait par des
discussions qui ont pu avoir lieu
informel entre chef de cours ou le
juridiction et par exemple le bâtonnier
que telle magistrat a fait
malheureusement
est insuffisant professionnellement
et que aucune conclusion d'en étirée
donc il y a à faire un travail de ce
côté là et puis sans doute sans doute
faut-il que le Conseil de la
magistrature comme cela a été proposé
d'ailleurs puisse faire appel
ponctuellement à aux inspecteurs
de la justice
évidemment avec l'accord du ministre de
la justice mais je crois que ce serait
important parce que les anciens membres
m'ont dit mais quand on examine le
dossier de justice de magistrats qui
sont visés par des plaintes nous n'avons
pas beaucoup
de nous n'avons pas beaucoup de
d'éléments en réalité sur la carrière
non pas et donc
voilà il me semble que que ça ce serait
ce serait une amélioration importante
moi je suis pas favorable du tout
à la proposition qui consisterait à
enlever l'inspection de la justice du
ministère de la Justice pour la mettre à
la disposition complètement du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature j'estime
que c'est au garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice de garder la disposition
de son inspection alors à notre sénateur
se manifeste monsieur bas
merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je vois bien le rôle
du Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
tel qu'il est défini par les articles 64
et 65 de la Constitution
il assiste le Président de la République
dans sa fonction de garant de
l'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
et à l'article 65 on voit le détail de
ces compétences et de son organisation
pour
les nominations et la discipline des
magistrats du siège et des magistrats du
parquet
y a-t-il de votre point de vue
à partir de ces dispositions de la
Constitution une légitimité pour le
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature a
intervenir dans le débat public sur les
matières relevant de la politique de la
justice aussi bien l'action du
gouvernement que le débat législatif du
Parlement
merci je pense que ce sera la dernière
question
il me semble que
le conseil de supérieur de la
magistrature
surtout lorsqu'il est saisi par le
Président de la République et encore une
fois je répète que je ne souhaite pas
qu'on est d'autosine je pense qu'il faut
s'en tenir là strictement
à la Constitution le Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature n'est saisi que par
le Président de la République qui
assiste sur
l'indépendance de la justice et il ou
par le garde des sceaux sur le
fonctionnement de la justice alors
évidemment lorsqu'il est saisi il
s'exprime bien normal sinon on voit pas
qu'elle serait son utilité donc et puis
par ailleurs c'est lors de ces missions
dans les juridictions qui d'ailleurs
deviennent plus nombreuses et qui à mes
yeux sont très utiles pour pouvoir dans
le dialogue d'ailleurs que le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature a avec la
direction des services judiciaires dans
ce travail commun qui d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup amélioré ces dernières années
pour le choix des magistrats ensuite
puisqu'il est garant de l'indépendance
en insistant le président de la
République évidemment sur ce plan-là
mais il est garant de l'indépendance de
la justice et d'ailleurs de la
production des droits fondamentaux le
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
doivent veiller en effet à ne pas
empiéter sur les prérogatives des autres
pouvoirs des pouvoirs puisque il n'y a
qu'une autorité judiciaire
selon notre Constitution
voilà c'est la raison pour laquelle mais
je ne vois pas ce qui peut lui interdire
de donner son opinion sur le
fonctionnement des juridictions y
compris à l'occasion de à l'occasion de
ces missions
d'information qui l'effectue
ni d'ailleurs de faire part de son
analyse de l'État de droit dans
différents pays puisque le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature a développé
beaucoup ses relations avec les conseils
de justice ou qui équivalents dans les
autres pays européens notamment ou dans
les pays francophones
voilà il me semble utile que le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature s'exprime
davantage d'ailleurs un secrétaire
général adjoint qui a été nommé pour la
communication je pense que c'est une
bonne chose mais qu'il le fasse en
respectant
les prérogatives
qui les chargée de des autres enfin des
pouvoirs téléchargés de faire respecter
pour la magistrature elle-même voilà je
pense que c'est un équilibre à tenir
tout ailleurs et je terminerai par là
monsieur le Président la séparation du
pouvoir c'est une question d'équilibre
entre les pouvoirs et cet équilibre est
naturellement évolutif selon les
évolutions historiques et les évolutions
de la société le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature lui-même d'ailleurs et très
différent de ce qu'il était lors de sa
création à la fin du 19e siècle je pense
qu'il faut admettre ces évolutions et
vérifier que les pouvoirs exécutifs et
législatives reste à même
d'exercer les fonctions que leur
attribut la Constitution voilà et la
Constitution restera ma référence et je
quel que soit ce que je peux souhaiter
des réformes
ultérieures du Conseil supérieur de la
magistature moi j'ai inscrirai mes
réflexions et mes décisions dans le
cadre de la Constitution telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui
merci Madame merci aux collègues d'avoir
posé la question merci des réponses que
vous avez apportées également à leurs
questions et
bien nous allons terminer cette audition
en vous disant que maintenant nous
allons procéder au vote comme je vous
l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure merci
tout à l'heure monsieur Waxman est
proposé pour être nommé au Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature par le
président du Sénat
nous voterons monsieur juste après votre
audition
et votre audition est retransmise en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
je vais vous donner immédiatement la
parole et puis ensuite il y aura sans
doute des questions de collègues et puis
voilà on a à peu près au maximum 45
minutes c'est les délais que nous sommes
donnés on peut faire moins mais pas
beaucoup plus
merci vous avez la parole monsieur
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs c'est
un très grand honneur pour moi de me
trouver aujourd'hui devant vous afin de
vous exposer les raisons qui m'ont
conduit à accepter la proposition du
président Larcher que je remercie très
vivement d'intégrer le Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature de la part d'un
spécialiste de droit administratifs plus
largement de droits publics une telle
ambition pour réparaître contre
intuitive je vais m'efforcer de vous
convaincre du contraire
mon parcours professionnel est celui
d'un universitaire qui s'est
particulièrement intéressé à une matière
vaste et fondamental bien entendu les
libertés publiques les libertés
publiques dans toute leur dimension de
me rendre tiens
pardonnez moi de vous infliger mais Mani
doctrinal je tiens à ce terme liberté
publique au pluriel qui a été consacré
au 19e siècle avant sous la Révolution
on parlait de la liberté publique au
singulier à partir de Chateaubriand et
de la colonne de Juillet de 1830 on
parle plus volontiers des libertés
publiques et dans le discours
républicain ce thème est
omniprésent de sorte que la notion de
droit fondamentaux ou de liberté
fondamentale qui aujourd'hui est plus
couramment employé me paraît ne
correspondent qu'à ces également
à vous donner de notre système juridique
assistant à la faculté de droit de
Strasbourg dès 1974 je consacre ma thèse
sous la direction du Professeur Paul
amslek au monopole publique
la justice s'y apparaît à travers la
justice pénale qui est un monopole par
la justice civile puisque il y a
sauf raison d'ordre public la
possibilité pour les parties privées de
recourir à l'arbitrage mais pas pour les
personnes publiques
l'interdiction de principe fait
notamment à l'état de recourir à
l'arbitrage
il fallait essayer d'en discerner les
raisons or on n'y arrive pas pas
vraiment la meilleure explication me
paraît être celle du Doyen George Vedène
qui faisait remarquer que nul ne ferait
confiance à un pâtissier qui achèterait
ses gâteaux chez la concurrence
je me suis spécialise donc en liberté
publique dès mon agrégation de droit
public en 1983 je suis d'abord nommé
professeur à Nancy et ensuite je rejoins
la faculté de droit de Strasbourg que
j'ai envie d'appeler ma faculté en 1987
spécialisation liberté publique puisque
théorie du droit histoire des idées
politiques contentieux administratif et
droit administratifs contentieux
constitutionnel et droits
constitutionnel protection européenne
des droits de l'homme sont autant de
disciplines qu'il est nécessaire de
convoquer pour rendre compte du régime
juridique des libertés en France
quelques évolutions qui sont souvent
considérables de ce régime des libertés
une constante demeure à savoir le
caractère irremplaçable du contrôle
juridictionnel du contrôle exercé par
des juges indépendants afin d'assurer le
respect des libertés et corollaire bien
sûr l'importance des voies de recours
l'importance des garanties procédurales
offertes à ce titre
l'étude de la jurisprudence de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
l'archement relayée par les juridictions
françaises y compris le Conseil
constitutionnel a encore renforcé cette
certitude de l'importance fondamentale
cardinal du juge
face aujourd'hui à la forte tendance des
médias en particulier des réseaux
sociaux à présenter les témoignages
recueillis par eux comme vallon
condamnation de la personne mise en
cause
l'importance des formes et des
procédures l'importance aussi de la
présomption d'innocence doit être plus
que jamais souligné c'est elle en effet
c'est important de la forme et de la
procédure qui différencie la
civilisation juridique de la loi du
Lynch qui est tout sauf une loi ou
encore de la pratique des régimes
totalitaires
qui ne sont bien entendu que d'autres
figures de la barbarie
on appartenance au Conseil supérieur de
la magistrature si vous y consentez me
permettrait de contribuer à renforcer
l'indépendance l'autorité l'impartialité
des magistrats de l'anti à mes
recherches et à mon enseignement un
prolongement dans l'exercice des
missions de nomination et d'exercices du
pouvoir disciplinaire qui incombe à cet
instant
le désir d'employer à l'émission de
service public autre que l'enseignement
et la recherche stricto sensu les
connaissances et les expériences
acquises à ce titre ne m'a d'ailleurs
jamais quitté
en tant que professeur j'ai été bien sûr
rappelé comme chacun a
recruter de jeunes collègues au sein de
mes facultés successives
d'affectation mais aussi au niveau
national assiégé au Conseil national des
universités et à deux reprises la
seconde en qualité de président dans les
jurys d'agrégation de droit public
la tâche de choisir les personnes les
plus dignes d'assumer certains emplois
publics offrent évidemment ici bien des
analogies avec les attributions du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature dès
lors que les fonctions à pourvoir
impliquent à la fois des compétences
professionnelles en droit cela devrait
être un minimum
insusceptible de donner lieu à
négociation bien sûr mais aussi
l'indépendance d'esprit
le respect également des usagers
partenaires du service public
ce sont les étudiants pour le service
assuré par les professeurs d'université
ce sont les autres magistrats les
justiciables bien sûr les avocats
dans le cas des magistrats
l'article 6 de la Déclaration des Droits
de l'Homme et du Citoyen dont je vois le
texte devant moi
en faisant des capacités le seul critère
pour l'accès aux emplois publics et on
interdit sans toute distinction autre
que celle des vertus et des talents des
candidats traces ici un cadre rigoureux
une fois identifié les capacités
requises et bien sûr dans le respect des
textes applicables
à ces missions directement liées à mes
fonctions professeur j'ai tenu en
ajouter d'autres de manière à m'investir
dans des aspects différents de la vie de
la cité je citerai notamment trois de
ces missions qui vont particulièrement
intéressé j'ai été délégué thématique du
Médiateur de la République pas encore
Défenseur des droits monsieur Jean-Paul
Delevoye puis
Dominique Baudis
à ce titre j'étais chargé de
signaler dans les évolutions
jurisprudentielles de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme celle qui me
paraissait appelée des réformes des
propositions de réforme de la part du
Défenseur des droits de celui qui
n'était pas encore le défenseur de
en second lieu j'ai été membre de 2011 à
2018 une commission informelle dont le
président du tribunal de grande instance
de Strasbourg avait eu l'initiative au
lendemain de l'adoption de la loi du 5
juillet 2011 à propos du régime des
soins psychiatriques contraints en effet
cette loi instaure et me semble que
c'est une chose excellente un contrôle
systématique du juge de liberté de la
détention lorsque la privation de
liberté s'étend au-delà de quelques
jours
il a fallu au début rassembler autour
d'une table les différents acteurs de
cette nouvelle procédure c'est à savoir
les magistrats les psychiatres les
directeurs d'établissements les avocats
et j'ai été très intéressé par cette
manière dont les différents acteurs
parvenaient à s'accorder après un temps
de méfiance perceptible très clair sur
la manière de travailler ensemble
j'ai été membre également en 2021 donc
plus récemment de la commission présidée
par le conseiller d'État Jean-Marie
Delarue qui avait été chargé par les
ministres de la Culture et de
l'intérieur de faire des propositions
afin d'améliorer les relations entre les
forces de l'ordre et la presse
enfin j'ai exercé les fonctions de
déontologue de la ville de Strasbourg
pour ce qui concerne les élus et ceci
depuis 2015 c'est-à-dire sous deux
mandatures successives
Strasbourg a été la première
collectivité territoriale française à se
doter d'un déontologue indépendant cette
mission comporte le conseil aux élus
notamment en vue de leur permettre
d'éviter de se trouver en situation de
conflit d'intérêt et de traiter les
problèmes
soulevés par ce risque sur lequel il
m'appartient évidemment de les
renseigner à ces précisément contenu le
ce qu'est la jurisprudence de la Cour de
cassation sur le délit de prise illégal
d'intérêt qui pose pas mal de
difficultés Mathilde semblait
le traitement également des requêtes que
les citoyens ont été autorisés à former
à l'encontre des élus lorsqu'ils
estiment que ceci ne se comporte pas
d'une manière fidèle par rapport aux
engagements résultant la charte de
déontologie enfin la rédaction de
recommandations et de rapport
cette expérience m'a rendu sensible aux
avancées récentes de la déontologie en
France à la constitution aussi d'un
corpus
constitué des travaux de diverses
instances en charge la déontologie et
d'abord bien sûr de la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
qui fait figure en quelque sorte dans ce
domaine de premier violon si je puis
dire
j'ai été frappé par le caractère en
réalité très délicat de beaucoup de
situations
qui conduisent à des préconisations très
complexes afin d'assurer le retrait du
processus décisionnel donne élu qui
serait à des titres divers trop
directement pardon impliqué
en quoi ces étapes d'un parcours qui a
été très riche de satisfaction diverses
trouverait-elle un aboutissement dans la
fonction de membres du Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature
la qualité de spécialiste du droit
public est en réalité pleinement
cohérente avec l'appartenance à ce
conseil comme La Teste d'ailleurs une
longue tradition il y a plein des
professeurs de droit public autrement
dit l'intuition dont je parlais en
commençant
et en réalité trompeuse en effet elle
est démenti en tout cas par les
enseignements du droit administratif
en effet ce que le titre 8 de notre
Constitution appelle l'autorité
judiciaire
ressortie à la compétence de la
juridiction administrative quant à son
organisation
opposée à son fonctionnement qu'il
relève que de la seule autorité
judiciaire elle-même ce qui conduit à la
parent paradoxe que les décisions prises
par le Conseil supérieur la magistrature
en tant que juridiction disciplinaire à
l'égard des magistrats du siège relèvent
du contrôle de cassation du Conseil
d'État
que la connaissance du contentieux de
cassation devant le Conseil d'État est
aujourd'hui d'autant plus importante que
dans une décision de 2023 à propos des
décisions du CNES
en matière disciplinaire le Conseil
d'État vient de renforcer le contrôle
qu'il exerce sur l'adéquation de la
sanction prononcée par
la juridiction disciplinaire au regard
de la gravité des faits dont l'agent a
été reconnu coupable c'est pleinement
transposable bien évidemment pour
l'avenir au contentieux auquel
l'activité du Conseil Supérieur la
magistrature pourrait donner lieu
l'attachement à l'indépendance c'est
essentiel pour moi fils et frère
d'avocat j'ai choisi une autre voie dans
les professions du droit mais il était
clair d'emblée pour moi que ce ne
pourrait être qu'une voix m'assurant une
liberté aussi large que possible
l'indépendance des professeurs
d'université et garantis par les
principes fondamentaux reconnus par les
lois de la République depuis une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel de
1984 c'est bien sûr l'article 64 de la
Constitution du 4 octobre 1958 qui
garantit celle des magistrats du parquet
comme du siège d'ailleurs
les fonctions de membres du Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature consiste
d'abord à mes yeux à oeuvrer en faveur
de cette indépendance
choisir entre plusieurs candidats des
responsabilités publiques faire vivre la
déontologie exercer la répression
disciplinaire au cas où la déontologie
aurait été gravement méconnue ces
responsabilités si vous acceptez de me
les confier je m'engage à les exercer
moi-même en toute indépendance
n'ayant jamais été membre d'un parti ou
d'un groupement politique j'aurais
évidemment à coeur de me
non non je n'ai pas sous-entendu
monsieur le sénateur que ce serait ce
mental
loin de moi cette idée je précise
simplement les choses
j'aurais évidemment à coeur de me
déterminer d'une manière impartiale
après examens attentif des éléments du
dossier et confiance dans les vertus de
la confrontation collégiale des points
de vue
l'autre système institutionnel est fait
d'équilibre subtil et d'ailleurs
changeant celles et ceux qui exercent
que Montesquieu dans l'esprit des lois
appelé la puissance de juger il la
qualifié on est au cœur des
contradictions
institutionnelles inévitable en la
matière comme en d'autres
Montesquieu qualifié la puissance de
juger à la fois de terrible et
d'invisible est nul contradiction
évidemment précisément ce qu'il s'agit
de gérer
c'est
magistrates et ces magistrats doit avoir
leur indépendance mais aussi leur
impartialité leur capacité leur vertus
et leurs talents pour citer encore une
fois l'article 6 de la déclaration du
1789 doté de la protection que requiert
les règles constitutionnelles je vous
remercie monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur y a-t-il des questions
monsieur d'Arnaud
oui merci monsieur le Président
merci pour cette présentation
j'aurais une une question puisque dans
votre présentation vous avez fait
référence notamment à vos fonctions de
déontologue à la ville de Strasbourg
et vous avez évoqué le sujet
potentiel du conflit d'intérêt vous avez
rappelé que vous avez pu observer des
situations que vous avez vous-même
qualifié de délicate
c'est un sujet dont nous avons
à plusieurs reprises ici
parler en commission des lois ou lors de
l'examen de différents textes s'agissant
notamment du statut de l'élu ou de
disposition si rapportent vous savez
évoqué que c'était pour vous finalement
mission imposte qui
relève d'un intérêt tout particulier et
qui peut avoir un prolongement dans les
futurs responsabilités auxquels vous
aspirez voulu avoir votre votre regard
sur le sur le sujet sur un sujet qui
devient de plus en plus complexe pour
pour nombre d'élus avec parfois une
ligne de crête assez difficile
singulièrement sur la question du
conflit d'intérêt voilà simplement avoir
votre votre regard sur ce sur ce sujet
merci Monsieur Danot Monsieur Philippe
bonne Carrère
j'étais comme mon collègue monsieur
d'Arnaud intrigué par votre activité
précédente de déontologue ou par votre
activité actuelle de déontologue à
Strasbourg j'avoue que je ne connaissais
pas ce système de déontologue dans des
collectivités dans des collectivités
locales
n'ont pas que je veille vous demander
une consultation même si c'était
s'habituel pour un professeur de droit
si vous nous avez indiqué que vous aviez
trois missions comme déontologue pour
comprendre à quoi cela correspond et un
finalement essayer de mieux percevoir
aujourd'hui un petit peu l'intimité du
fonctionnement de nos collectivités sans
bien sûr aucune référence personnelle
est-ce que vous pouvez me donner
quelques exemples de sujets qui vous ont
été soumis dans cette fonction nouvelle
pour nous de déontologue de
collectivités locales merci
je compléterai volonté la question par
le fait qu'au sein du Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature il y a une démarche
déontologique et que vient se rajouter à
cela
non pas la remise en cause mais en tous
les cas une évolution quand à l'analyse
de la responsabilité des magistrats dans
l'exercice de World fonction puisque ça
vient notamment d'une demande du
Président de la République et d'un
rapport qui a déjà été commis par le
Conseil supérieur magistrature donc on
sent d'ailleurs depuis les auditions de
ce matin la
prééminence de la déontologie à l'égard
des magistrats donc c'était dans le
complément parce qu'il y a des
bien merci de ces questions
la question du conflit d'intérêt est une
question évidemment très très difficile
parce que
nous avons tous une approche intuitive
de ce qu'est le conflit d'intérêt il
s'agit de cas évident
vente d'un terrain communal à sinon au
maire lui-même tout au moins un membre
de sa famille ou un très proche ami là
bien sûr les choses sont évidentes et il
faut que le maire évite de se mêler à la
décision absolument et se rendre même
coupable du délit de prise illégal
d'intérêt s'il venait à participer à la
délibération et donc se déporter mais il
y a les situations beaucoup plus
compliquées et qui posent bien sûr des
questions importantes c'est alors pour
répondre à votre question
monsieur le sénateur c'est la question
de
la manière dont le passé professionnel
évidemment pleinement légitime même plus
que ça souhaitable d'un élu le conduire
à avoir des des problèmes difficiles
dans la gestion de certains dossiers
exemple d'un architecte qui a exercé et
qui se retire assez largement lorsqu'il
est élu de ses responsabilités
professionnelles anciennes mais qui
évidemment va être confronté à des
demandes éventuelles émanant de ces
anciens associés de personnes dont il
est proche par ailleurs ou encore de
personnes avec lesquelles c'est aussi
une phase du conflit d'intérêt bien sûr
il est en
litige et en opposition notoire depuis
des années la question se pose notamment
de savoir par exemple au bout de combien
d'années on peut considérer que les
liens d'intérêt en question se
dissolvent
est-ce que ces trois ans est-ce que
c'est 5 ans est-ce que c'est ta vie on
peut l'envisager bien entendu il y a des
relations de proximité qui en réalité ne
sont jamais effacées par le passage du
temps me semble-t-il mais c'est
évidemment de plus en plus difficile à
gérer à mesure que on s'éloigne de
l'époque où l'intéresser exercer ses
responsabilités
en ce qui concerne la responsabilité des
magistrats au regard de la déontologie
effectivement
il y a eu un effort très important des
conseils supérieurs de la magistrature
précédente donc il y a une continuité
institutionnelle bien sûr cela continue
de valoir pour le prochain
jusqu'à changement des préconisations il
y a évidemment une
sensibilité croissante à la déontologie
il est de plus en plus clair qu'un
magistrat comme tout fonctionnaire mais
encore plus que les fonctionnaires
ordinaire si je puis dire qu'ils n'ont
pas le privilège de ce statut
d'indépendance comme magistrat doit être
très prudent dans la manifestation de
ces opinions il a la liberté
d'expression le Conseil l'a rappelé
dans une décision récente mais
évidemment il y a aussi
l'obligation de réserve il est clair que
jusqu'à un certain point on peut
librement fort heureusement même quand
on est magistrat si je puis dire
exprimer des opinions politiques mais il
y a évidemment la limite de la décence
du ton et du risque aussi que les
positions prises puissent paraître
menacés l'impartialité de ce magistrat
lorsqu'il viendrait à traiter certaines
affaires il convient donc me semble-t-il
que la règle du déport puisse être
largement utilisé
merci y a-t-il d'autres questions
pas de question
bien moi j'ai peut-être
je ne crois pas remarqué avoir des
questions supplémentaires vous avez
répondu sur le point qui me paraît
essentiel enfin un des points importants
qui concerne la responsabilité la
déontologie qui est vraiment qui va être
un sujet important d'autant plus que le
recrutement de 1500 magistrats
supplémentaires qui va être fait
et de surcroît dans ce qu'on n'a pas
forcément pas par la voix dit tout on
voit qualifier de Royal d'accès à l'Onem
mais par des voix autres nécessitent que
dans ce la formation dans le cadre de ce
recrutement soit parfaitement contrôlé
on va vous libérer on vous remercions de
votre intervention de vos propos et nous
allons procéder au vote pour tout vous
dire et je pense que d'ici 12h30 nous
aurons les résultats
[Musique]